you look cool now you really screwed me
up why I did not think you are the best
singer do you know how hard it was for
me to keep that secret who knew and your
family just my mom and my brother but
that was it but like literally the only
people I told besides my best friend
Daniel because everyone else had to sign
an NDA and I knew that if I told my dad
like I said before he would have told
everyone because he's like a proud
father so it was so so I was like no
there's no and then after I went back
and looked at the clues like a real
idiot and I was like it should I should
have known it was you it was so fun to
throw fun I was cool you know it was a
really interesting experience because
it's a little bit lonely you don't see
you speak to anyone all day and you're
in that trail of like 12 hours and you
know you just feel very secluded but I
learnt a lot of my entertainment from
doing that show because you don't have
any backstory you don't have anything to
go on other than little tiny clues and
to make people like your character and
have it be you but not too close to who
you are so they don't guess I gave us
just it but it's not my courage back
giving that show well here's the thing I
was gonna say is that you were
absolutely like whaling and does this
mean you're thinking about maybe more
music I've heard a lot of people off me
and like a lot of producers contact me
since the show I didn't expect that to
happen I wouldn't I can't say enough I
didn't do the show to reignite my
musical career I did it to get my
confidence back and that it gave me but
I've been getting hit on by a lot of
producers so I don't know maybe
tell me about your fashion is their
secret to this dress you look sick thank
you so much a this squatty body you've
been [ __ ] I have been in the gym buddy
first you know my first year of sobriety
I did the mind my second year of
sobriety I did the body but looking at
my cheat sheet okay
great a my my earrings Dana Rebecca my
rings are I need to Cohen Effie and my
dresses vampires wife is my favorite
favorite new designer and my earrings
are Tyler Ellis no my god no fashion of
new faster faster keep making that
mistake and it's like goin with my
history of fashion please I can't come
up here but I don't know so I have my
stylist Molly would like to see another
Kelly album you know what maybe maybe
I'm ready to I don't know I don't know I
don't know got to old now I'm 35
oh god you're not that old
thank you so much pal thanks for coming
back I appreciate you there
[Music]